jackson kolar hits the ball tonight he
made his second big league start against
oakland back in june and he's hoping for
much better results tonight and harrison
starts it off with a walk so from
harrison to starling martay basketball
that's line hard to left ben attendee
gives chase can't get it and lands
toward the corner up around first on his
way to second is marte from first to
third goes harrison and the a's are in
business runners at second and third
with nobody out for matt olson
this one is hit in the air right field
dozier underneath it
harrison's tagging harrison's going to
come in
he's going to score and going to third
is marta sacrifice fly moves up both
runners and olson has rbi number 99.
martine now at third base one down here
comes jed lowry best ball stroke toward
left
out there's ben 10 he'll make the catch
martay tagging here comes the throw and
starling scores standing up another sac
fly for the a's this one off the bat of
jed lowry and it's two nothing oakland
and now mark khanna coming up two two
pitches swung on and missed so two runs
on one hit lead off walk to sac flies
they'll be staring down frankie montas
who over the last four outings has been
superb for the oakland a's kite been
filling up the strike zone early and
often we know about that devastating
split finger fastball he's got coming in
tow and one down for nikki lopez
nikki grounds out through the right side
so one pitch into the home stand and he
extends his hitting streak to 10 and is
on base streak to 23. here comes the
locomotive the big bus it is salvador
perez
and a high fastball and perez swung and
missed a little challenge fastball that
was elevated and that's the second out
so two on two out carlos santana who has
really fought us since the all-star
break swung on him blooped into shallow
no it's not even shallow cena just
behind second base elvis is there to
make the catch and the inning is over
jackson koar has walked the bases loaded
here in the second inning first pitch to
elvis andrews
is lying to center and that's the base
hit played on a hop by isbell is
hustling in the score is brown rbi
single for elvis andrews and it's three
to nothing so elvis must have had a plan
i mean first three guys in front of you
all walk sitting on a fastball and you
know what it's not a bad plan if you
think about it and now back around with
josh harrison
and that's a base hit right center field
murphy's gonna score kemp's gonna come
in to score
going to third everybody's safe there
and moving up to second is harrison and
it's five to nothing
that is gonna do it for jackson koar the
young right-hander one plus innings five
runs urban santana coming on in relief
runners at second and third nobody out
and a fastball
is a strike that swing will not be on
his highlight reel now matt olson
olson grounds it to monteci
and a rundown with andrews
and olsen is halfway between first and
second but there's nobody for salvi to
throw to irvin santana comes in with
runners at second and third and nobody
out and he gets a strikeout in an out on
the bases so a five to two put out on
the fielder's choice and now lowry
change up popped him up boy what a job
urban santana did monday near third to
make the catch
irvin santana
he made it look as easy as kowar made it
look tough so canna will get third base
for free and the royals in danger of
going down six nothing
that's a swing so irving gets another
out with the runner at third base and
nobody out canada has to hold at third
base and the battle will be sean murphy
a right-handed batter
pitch that one bounces away cannon's
gonna come in to score and it's six
nothing and even with somebody as great
as the five-time gold glover salvador
perez he's not on one knee you know this
is this is the new norm like so many
other different things about the way the
game is presented so two on one out for
elvis andrews who had an rbi single in
the second inning
and there's a line drive caught by nikki
lopez
not in time so they're unable to get
that double play back to the top of the
order and josh harrison there's the
pitch a little comebacker to santana
he'll go to first record the out but
oakland comes up with one more run on
three hits and the royals have a runner
at second with nobody out and
whitmerfield now the batter
ground ball right side that's a base hit
is bell is going to be waved home
brown's throw is cut off
whit has his first hit
and isbell's lead off double turns into
a run that falls up fastball didn't try
to do too much watch me lets the ball
travel and now with one out width is in
scoring position and the battery will be
salvador perez
and he grounds one up the middle and
into center field
so here comes whit around third
salvia has driven in 106.
and now it's 6-2
well they were playing salvi to pull so
the shortstop was pulled way over
towards third base and salvi hit it
where the shortstop had vacated and the
bases are loaded with one out the royals
have two in the inning and now the tying
run is at the plate at alberto mondessie
monteci pulls it
over the right side the a's will get it
out the royals will get another run
salvi comes down from third monday gets
an rbi the royals cut the oakland lead
to three hunter dozier leading off near
the bottom of the fourth
and hunter hits it well
deep left center field martay is back it
is gone
and it's a two-run game yeah that's what
you can do and hunter can do with a
fastball he loves
hitting that fastball about 97 miles an
hour and here it comes right down the
middle of the plate and he didn't miss
it and there's two on with one out three
and a third innings and that's going to
do it for frankie muntos montas had not
allowed four or more runs since june
21st that is the fifth inning in a row
the a's have had their lead off man
aboard so two outs now it's up to elvis
to try to make something happen
three two pitches line to left center
field and that's a base hit
brown will score elvis is gonna try for
two and elvis is gonna be
safe big two out hit for albus anders to
make it seven to four he's needed that
first and third one out and another
chance nikki lopez coming up wit's
running
and nikki lines it off of kemp's glove
isbell scores nikki lopez joins with
merrifield with three hits tonight and
we're back to a two-run game
oh man he picked the right guy to hit it
to one of the smallest guys in baseball
right there he just couldn't climb up
and get it with runners now at second
and third the tying run and scoring
position for salvia petite deals perez
swings drives it deep to left that's a
way back and that ball is out of here
the royals have come all the way back
from a six-run deficit and salvador
perez blasting his 43rd home run this
year has given the royals an eight to
seven lead you can't sneak a piece of
cheese by a hungry salvy and ryan has
reached now isabel who's had a good game
comes up he's two for three
isbell
into the right field corner
gone
for his first big league home run kyle
isbell with his first major league home
run gives the royals a 10 to seven lead
that's the insurance runs the royals are
talking about now va's have two on and
nobody out back-to-back walks 2-0 the
count to jan gomes
gomes hits a ground ball to short
out at second there's your double play
ball head
and just at the right time i knew he had
it in him so that pushes the tying run
from
at home plate to back to the on deck
circle and a runner to third but now
there are two out
in the air left field ben and tendy
waits
what a night and the royals come back is
complete 10-7 the final
[Applause]